deux mois après le décès de sa mère
l'émotion est toujours là
difficile d'expliquer que ce 14
septembre
les services d'urgence ont peut-être
commis une erreur et dit greffier avait
62 ans
à la fin d'un déjeuner en famille elle
ne se sent pas bien sa fille appelle le
une première fois quand je dis douleur
bras gauche
sueur pâleur elle a du mal à respirer
et elle a vomi j'essaie de rester très
calme même si j'étais complètement
paniqué car moi j'avais compris de mon
côté que c'était un infarctus de salut
bonjour ou deuxième appel les mêmes
questions mais le diagnostic est vite
expédié comme l'attestent
l'enregistrement de les changes avec le
15 il ya beaucoup de buts frau en ce
moment donc il ya une ambulance qui va
venir la prendre un qui fera là dans
l'heure qui vient une demi heure plus
tard nouvelles abel l'état de la
sexagénaire sa gratte pour autant oui
bonjour je voudrais pas encore maman qui
est donc en musique elle est en train de
se la pète un plomb madame greffiers
elle ne respire plus alors il faut vous
venez tout y est d'après 20 minutes que
vous dépêchez vous une ambulance privée
arrive au bout de 40 minutes
les infirmiers ne savent pas qu'il
s'agit d'une urgence vitale edit
greffier est déjà en arrêt
cardio-respiratoire le samu lui arrivera
une heure après le premier appel
il aurait pu envoyer entre temps les
pompiers qui sont à 3 minutes de chez
mes parents
moi je pense que le problème c'est que
depuis 2015 on a plus de centre d'appels
sur belfort montbéliard
on appelle à besançon je ne vois pas
comment un besançon on peut savoir où se
situe et lachapelle sous chaux
est-ce qu'ils ont la mesure de savoir
qui avait deux casernes à proximité la
famille a demandé les enregistrements
des appels
ils sont arrivés après plusieurs
relances et incomplet sur ce premier cd
mon premier rappel avait été coupé mon
deuxième un pays n'était pas mon
troisième appel n'y était pas on m'avait
en fait coupé un pour moi les éléments
et puis incriminant selon la famille il
n'y avait aucune épidémie de gastro à
cette époque là en tout cas pas à
belfort
la fille des dites greffier a porté
plainte contre le samu pour
non-assistance à personne en danger